but did china touch bitcoin no did they  touch the network no did they physically  confiscate any bitcoin in canada no you  literally can't do that now you can ban  bitcoin you can't stop bitcoin so in  relation to that point about china yes  they ban bitcoin mining but number one  people still mine bitcoin and they still  hold bitcoin in china but that's  whatever of course it had a short-term  effect on the network because a lot of  miners obviously had to go offline which  affect network they had to relocate but  within few weeks a few months the hash  power was back up and the network was  working perfectly fine so regardless of  what china wanted to do it didn't really  matter  [Music]